dans l'actualité ce soir un accident
grave au stade vélodrome à marseille une
scène érigée pour le concert de madonna
s'est effondré il y à un mort et neuf
blessés le concert est annulé
attention aux orages la moitié de la
france s'est placée en alerte la foudre
est la grêle sont attendus ce soir et
cette nuit tu 55 départements sont
concernés
la cour des comptes épingle l'elysée sur
ses dépenses elle demande des économies
sur les voyages et même sur
l'alimentation
on apprend que nicolas sarkozy a
remboursé 14000 euros de dépenses
privées prises en charge par la
présidence
les locataires vont devoir payer une
partie des travaux d'économie d'énergie
décidés par le grenelle de
l'environnement
l'une des formules proposées est un
forfait mensuel de 20 euros
une vidéo inédite de michael jackson
elle montre comment le chanteur a eu les
cheveux et le crâne brûlés lors du
tournage d'une publicité
cette blessure aurait été l'un des
éléments déclencheurs de ses ennuis de
santé
les célébrations du 40e anniversaire de
l'homme sur la lune ce soit on verra
comment les américains comptent
installer une base lunaire permanent à
l'horizon 2020 et dans quel but
enfin nous irons dans le nord près de
bergues à la rencontre de la famille des
reines du bac 4 filles quatre mentions
très bien jamais sous les 18 de moyenne
reportage tout à l'heure bonsoir et
bienvenue à tous marseille se préparait
pour la fête madonna était attendu sur
place dimanche soir
eh bien le concert n'aura pas lieu il
était un peu plus de 17 heures lorsque
la scène s'est écroulé plusieurs
personnes se trouvaient sous la
structure il ya un mort et neuf blessés
dont un très grièvement
stephen despinoy christophe la rocca sur
place voici ce qui reste de la scène qui
devait accueillir le concert de madonna
ce week-end un enchevêtrement de
ferraille et de toiles sur la pelouse du
vélodrome
la structure s'est effondrée vers 17
heures cette personne participante au
montage se sont retrouvées prises au
piège
c'est un espèce de
de château de cartes s'est effondré donc
évidemment c'était d'aller sur les lieux
pour vérifier qu'il ya plus personne
nous avons mis en place une équipe
cynotechnique donc avec des chiens qui
sont entraînés pour ça et qu'ils ont
fait ce travail
à l'arrivée des secours il est déjà trop
tard pour l'un des ouvriers en dépit des
efforts de réanimation de l'équipe
technique l'homme un français de 53 ans
a succombé à une crise cardiaque
six autres personnes ont été plus ou
moins grièvement blessé s'agissant des
blessés graves un a déjà été évacuée et
l'autre est en train d'être je dirais
préparer puisque ce sont des gens
polytraumatisé
c'est une société anglaise qui
s'occupait du montage de la scène pour
la tournée de madonna
l'enquêté va devoir déterminer des
responsabilités les fans de madonna ne
retrouveront pas leur chanteuse au
vélodrome
le concert de dimanche est d'ores et
déjà annulés on vous retrouve en direct
sur place stéphane despinoy bonsoir vous
avez des nouvelles des personnes
blessées est bien david selon le dernier
bilan de l'ap-hm l'assistance publique
des hôpitaux de marseille veut pour une
personne le pronostic vital est engagé
un autre patient est en observation et
un autre blessé et moins lourdement
atteint voilà donc pour les trois
personnes les plus blessé dans ce drame
il souffre de polytraumatismes ou de
traumatismes crâniens
à cela s'ajoute vie blessés légers ça
c'est pour donc le bilan qui est fournie
par l'ap-hm ce soir tout est allé très
vite comme vous avez pu le constater les
secours sont allées vite mais la
surprise a donc été au coeur de ce drame
c'est les quatre grues qui ont soulevé
le toit de la scène et c'est ce qui a
déséquilibré
ce toit doullens show de jean chevrette
roman de tôles et de poutrelles qui
s'est effondré sur ces personnes et
l'une d'elles a été prise au piège au
point de faire un seul arrêt cardiaque
stéphane des pinots à marseille merci
stéphane pour ces dernières précisions
en bref des nouvelles du site total de
carling en moselle après l'explosion
d'hier
le travail a repris une information
judiciaire va être ouverte on apprend
que l'installation avait été arrêté
lundi dernier après un incident
électrique
quatre des six blessés ont quitté
l'hôpital on en vient cette alerte aux
orages qui touchent la moitié du pays
météo france a émis un bulletin de
vigilance orange et appelle à la plus
grande prudence
il y aura de violentes rafales de fortes
pluies parfois de la grêle
il est recommandé d'éviter d'utiliser le
téléphone et les appareils électriques
sophie mais elle à la location les
prévisionnistes de météo france sont sur
le pied pierre jusqu'à demain matin 55
départements sont en vigilance orange
ces risques de rage ici on sait pas
encore les prévoir de façon très précise
en dépit des millions de données
analysées en continu en provenance des
stations météo des radars et des
satellites
c'est encore très difficile de dire 12
ou 24 heures à l'avancé que telle
commune par exemple va subir un orage
mais plutôt au niveau de risque au
niveau d'un département par exemple il y
a dix sept ans à vaison-la-romaine la
météo n'avait pas fait prévoir la
violence des orages et l'intensité de
leurs pluies diluviennes et même si la
science a progressé la météo n'a pas non
plus prévu les torrents qui se sont
déversées sur chézy sur marne après de
violents orages
le mois dernier
les orages fascine autant qu'il font
peur l'énergie qu'ils produisent peut
être dix fois supérieure à celle de la
bombe d'hiroshima
ils naissent de la rencontre entre masse
d'air chaud et froid se forme alors un
cumulonimbus ou nuages qui peut
atteindre 10 km2 au large est brassée
comme dans une lessiveuse et petit à
petit sa charge électrique va rencontrer
celle du sol c'est la foule
en 2009 sur les six premiers mois de
l'année il y a eu déjà 190 milles
impacts de foudre en bref un drame sur
la route deux jeunes filles de 14 et 16
ans membre d'un groupe de scouts ont été
fauché et tué par une voiture au bord
d'une départementale dans l'yonne
elle était assise sur le bas côté le
conducteur de la voiture a été placé en
garde à vue on n'en sait pas plus pour
l'instant
autre actualité de cette journée la
grippe a le bilan s'emballe brusquement
en grande bretagne les autorités
sanitaires ont annoncé cet après midi
que le virus a fait 29 morts 26 en
angleterre trois en écosse la plupart
des victimes ont moins de 14 ans
cinquante cinq mille personnes sont
contaminées et cherie blair l'épousé de
l'ex-premier ministre présente elle même
les symptômes de la maladie en france
une nouvelle colonie de vacances est
touché à condé sur vire dans la manche
quatre adultes et deux enfants sont
malades mais leur cas ne suscite pas
d'inquiétude ils viennent tous de
belgique
hier le gouvernement a livré des
informations sur les commandes de
vaccins et on en sait davantage
aujourd'hui sur les modalités de cette
campagne de vaccination à l'automne
ce rappel obligatoire combien
faudra-t-il d'injection les questions et
les réponses avec josé blanc lapierre et
alexis jacquet
toutes choses d'échappée cet automne
retour en force de la grippe a
la rentrée se prépare donc aujourd'hui
avec la commande ferme de près de 100
millions de vaccins livraison d'octobre
à janvier
comment se faire vacciner deux
injections par personne à trois semaines
d'intervalle
cette protection contre le h1n1 n'exclut
pas de se faire vacciner contre la
grippe saisonnière pour ceux qui en ont
l'habitude
en particulier les personnes âgées est
ce obligatoire
non il n'y aura aucune obligation de se
faire vacciner
la proposition sera faite en priorité
aux personnels soignants aux femmes
enceintes ou jeunes entre 3 et 18 ans
aux malades comme les diabétiques des
insuffisants respiratoires ou se faire
vacciner dans les centres médicaux les
lieux de travail et les écoles car les
vaccinations se feront collectivement
y at il d'autres modes de prévention
lavage des mains fréquent port de
masques en cas de doute les gestes
citoyens seront rappelés à la rentrée
par une campagne d'information dans les
écoles quels sont les risques
la pneumopathie est une complication de
la grippe h1n1
elle peut se déclarer chez les jeunes en
parfaite santé avant la contagion le
taux de mortalité est identique à celui
de la grippe saisonnière 1 cas pour
mille je vous le disais en titre si vous
faites partie des 11 millions de foyers
locataire vous devrez payer vous aussi
pour les travaux d'économie d'énergie
décidés par le grenelle de
l'environnement
l'une des formules proposées est un
forfait mensuel de 20 euros on l'a
appris aujourd'hui les propriétaires
restent toutefois les premiers
contributeurs explications romain mais
si arnaud jeune un logement plus
écologique rimera bientôt avec un loyer
plus cher le gouvernement a tranché les
propriétaires qui effectueront des
travaux d'économie d'énergie dans leur
logement pourront demander une
contribution à leurs locataires
l'option la plus simple un forfait de 20
euros par mois ajouté au prix du loyer
le dispositif né du grenelle de
l'environnement veut inciter les
français à avoir des logements moins
coûteux en énergie en améliorant par
exemple l'isolation des murs mais la
participation financière réclamée
aujourd'hui aux locataires dans un
contexte de crise
fait bondir les associations de
consommateurs qui réclame des
contreparties
on demande que cette participation elle
puisse faire l'objet d'un crédit d'impôt
pour les locataires concernés et
également qu'elles soient prises en
compte dans le calcul des aides au
logement
le locataire pourra toujours dire non
aux travaux d'économie d'énergie
effectuées dans son appartement mais il
ne pourra pas les refuser dans les
parties communes de l'immeuble comme par
exemple la modernisation du chauffage
collectif et toujours à propos de notre
porte-monnaie sa cheikh le taux du
livret a va être ramenée de 1,75 à 1,25
pour cent c'est ce qu'a annoncé la
ministre de l'économie christine lagarde
sur rtl
c'est la conséquence du recul de
l'inflation les prix ont baissé de 0 5%
sur les 12 derniers mois selon le calcul
en vigueur le taux du livret a aurait
même dû être ramené à 0 25% toujours
dans l'actualité sociale elle les
conséquences de la crise après
l'entreprise nortel
ce sont les salariés du site de pièces
automobiles fabris de chatellerault qui
menacent de faire sauter leur usine en
liquidation judiciaire et certains
d'entre vous le voyez ont manifesté
aujourd'hui devant les sièges de renault
et peugeot pour obtenir une prime de 30
mille euros ils ont obtenu pour
l'instant 3300 euros de la farb chacun
des groupes
la crise qui semble presque oublié dans
certains secteurs de la finance
américaine
on l'évoqué tiers les bénéfices et les
bonus repartent en flèche comme si rien
n'avait changé
nous avons posé la question au ministre
américain de l'économie timothy geitner
en visite aujourd'hui à paris reportage
jean paul chapelle c'est lui qui tient
les finances américaines le plus proche
ministre de barack obama fait escale à
paris au moment même où la bourse de new
york
renouer avec des profits insolents la
banque goldman sachs vient d'annoncer
des bénéfices de 3,4 milliards de
dollars et plus encore elle a mis de
côté 6,7 milliards de dollars pour payer
les bonus des traders et des dirigeants
33 % de plus que l'an dernier
ça ne choque même pas le grand argentier
américain ce qu'on constate aux etats
unis c'est que la confiance revient avec
le retour de la stabilité financière
et c'est encourageant voilée marché qui
recommence à mieux fonctionner la
ministre française promet d'être très
vigilante sur la distribution effective
de ces bonus mais la critique la plus
virulente est venue d'un conseiller de
l'elysée
c'est un scandale absolu on ne peut pas
construire une société sur ces bases là
on ne peut pas construire un système
économique sur sur ces bases là c'est
honteux
la banque goldman sachs n'existerait
plus si le contribuable américain
n'était pas venu à son secours et au
secours de tout léman les rémunérations
excessives des banquiers ont été
dénoncés par les chefs d'état réunis
lors du sommet historique du g20 leur
volonté d'y mettre fin risque de n'être
qu'un voeu pieux
c'est une première depuis louis saez la
cour des comptes a réalisé un contrôle
et un rapport sur les dépenses de
l'elysée bilan globalement positif mais
la présidence est épinglée sur plusieurs
points les voyages et les dépenses
d'alimentation notamment julien beaumont
c'est la meilleure adresse de l'elysée
une boucherie parisienne qui fournit la
présidence depuis 40 ans et monsieur
yvon peut garder sourire en 2008 il a
reçu un chèque de 130 mille euros madeco
m'ont dit qu'ils sont tous les jours les
quantités sont variables on n'a pas de
de quantité spécifique pour la première
fois la cour des comptes a pu
s'intéresser au budget de l'elysée les
caisses de la présidence contrôler cela
ne s'était pas vu depuis louis saez
mais impossible de savoir si les
dépenses dérapent car il n'y a pas
d'élément de comparaison sur un budget
de 110 millions d'euros par an on peut
entrer dans le détail notamment sur les
frais de bouche 126 mille euros de
boissons non-alcoolisées 120 me de
crémerie 275000 de fleurs mais aussi 155
mille euros de linge de maison plus que
le montant des dépenses la cour des
comptes souhaiterait que l'elysée fasse
appel à plus de fournisseurs pour
favoriser la concurrence
autre dépense les résidences du
président de belles demeures avec
gardien et jardiniers à l'année résultat
les charges de fonctionnement explosent
alors que le président n'y va pas
rambouillet un million deux cent mille
euros marly-le-roi 330000 souzy la
briche 230000 autant de lieux que
l'elysée souhaite mettre à la
disposition du ministère de la culture
un rapport qui a permis de lever
quelques erreurs et nicolas sarkozy a
remboursé 14000 euros de sa poche
république a été conduit à rembourser
une partie de ce home cash son insu nous
avons la conviction avait été payée à
tort comme dépenses publiques alors
qu'il s'agissait de dépenses élevées
mais l'elysée n'est pas toujours un bon
payeur pdf ainsi réclamé 2000 405 euros
pour retard de paiement
la justice la sphère liliane bettencourt
devrait bien donné lieu à un procès vous
le savez l'héritière de l'oréal femme la
plus riche d'europe âgé aujourd'hui de
86 ans a versé un milliard d'euros de
dons ces dernières années au photographe
françois-marie banier devenu l'un de ses
amis proches pour sa fille elle a été
d'une certaine manière abuser car elle
ne disposerait plus de toutes ses
facultés
ce que dément liliane bettencourt la
milliardaire et le photographe c'est le
dossier de cette édition il est signé
loïc de la mornais thierry breton
il n'existe que de très rares photos
d'elle encore moins d'imagés encore
moins des interviews liliane bettencourt
est une femme très discrète alors le
combat se déroule à pas feutrés mais il
est violent et l'enjeu colossal
héritière du groupe l'oréal liliane
bettencourt est à la tête d'une fortune
estimée à 10 milliards d'euros
même si ses gains ont un peu fondu cette
année elle reste la 21e fortune mondiale
la troisième de france et demeure la
plus riche femme d'europe depuis une
vingtaine d'années l'héritière avait
noué une relation amicale avec cet homme
françois-marie banier peintre et
photographe il réalise notamment des
campagnes de publicité comme ici pour
une grande maison de couture au fil des
ans le photographe aurait reçu de
nombreux chèques cadeaux de la part de
sa richissime annie au total des dons
d'environ un milliard d'euros
c'est en tout cas l'avis de la fille de
liliane bettencourt françoise ici en
écharpe bleue déjà héritière des parts
du groupe
elle est persuadée que sa mère s'est
fait abuser et a porté plainte contre le
photographe saleh certains chèques
certains dons sont 250 millions arrivé
vite à 500 millions ou 1 milliard
quand il y à des tableaux aussi réputés
que des jericho ou des tableaux de ce
genre là des matisse on va très vite des
sommes très importantes
je pose alors la question de savoir si
donné un milliard d'euros un homme qui
n'est rien ce n'est pas en soi un acte
de faiblesse en décembre dernier sortant
exceptionnellement de sa réserve
liliane bettencourt a accordé une
interview au journal du dimanche
indiquant je n'ai plus envie de voir ma
fille il faudrait tout de même que ma
fille se rende compte que je suis une
femme libre
le journaliste qui l'a interviewé assure
l'avoir trouvée saine d'esprit c'est
quelqu'un d'assez timide d'assez discret
et le fait qu'on puisse la présenté
publiquement comme une personne un peu
diminué ou une personne sous influence
c'est quelque chose qui semble-t-il la
blesse profondément
trouvant que la justice s'éternise la
fille bettencourt a adressé une citation
directe à comparaître au photographe
pour abus de faiblesse une procédure
coûteuse que ne peut pas s'offrir tout
le monde mais qui accélère la tenue d'un
procès si la fille bettencourt est
inquiète ce n'est pas que pour le don
d'un milliard d'euros sa mère possède
encore en effet 1% des actions du groupe
l'oréal en pleine propriété
6e 1% revenait par exemple en cadeau aux
photographes la famille bettencourt ne
serait alors plus majoritaire dans le
groupe
son actionnaire majoritaire deviendrai
messelet déjà propriétaire de 30% de
l'oréal
bien au delà d'une rivalité familiale se
cache donc un enjeu industriel
considérable
je vous le disais tout à l'heure trois
semaines après la mort de michael
jackson
une vidéo inédite a été diffusée
aujourd'hui elle montre comment le
chanteur a eu les cheveux et le crâne
brûlés lors du tournage d'une publicité
cette blessure aurait été l'un des
éléments déclencheurs de ses ennuis de
santé à répétition
anne guéri dominique bonnet il y avait
là 3000 figurants
la scène était truffé de fumigènes ce 27
janvier 1984 michael jackson tourne un
film publicitaire pour une boisson
gazeuse un énorme show pyrotechnique
il en est à sa sixième prise quand des
fumigènes explosent bien trop tôt juste
au dessus de lui ses cheveux
s'enflamment et michael danse ils
dansent encore ne se rend compte de rien
son crâne s'embrase
michael jackson est évacuée il est brûlé
au troisième degré pour beaucoup ce
jour-là signe le début de l'addiction
aux médicaments à tous qui anesthésie la
douleur le moment où michael jackson
commence à prendre des analgésiques pour
calmer la douleur de cette greffe de
peau consécutive à sa brûlure il
franchit un pacte qu'il n'avait encore
jamais franchi c'est à dire qu'ils
découvrent de médicaments s'était pas
dans sa culture ce n'était pas dans sa
religion de l'époque les témoins de
jéhovah et à partir de là il va mettre
malheureusement oui le trou dans un
engrenage partir de là effectivement
michael jackson s'est renfermé c'est à
partir de là on a commencé à dire qu'il
était bizarre étrange différents michael
jackson en torche humaine c'est le
dernier buzz sur internet
comme si ses fans cherchait encore à
élucider l'énigme du génie et de la
douleur
les célébrations du 40e anniversaire de
l'homme sur la lune la cérémonie à cap
canaveral aujourd'hui en présence de
buzz aldrin 79 ans l'un des deux hommes
à avoir foulé le sol lunaire lors de
cette première mission
alors hier on évoquait ces images
d'histoire ce soir nous parlons du futur
la nasa a décidé l'homme va retourner
sur la lune à l'horizon 2020
nicolas chateauneuf il ya près de 40 ans
des astronautes foulé la surface de la
lune est certain qu'ils roulaient à bord
d'une jeep depuis plus personne et elle
est là bas mais les choses pourraient
changer
en 2020 la lune pourrait de nouveau
accueillir quelques humains puis
pourquoi pas une place permanente
c'est l'ambition de la nasa de l' agence
spatiale européenne déjà les américains
mettent au point dans le désert de
drôles d'engins d'exploration capable de
parcourir des dizaines de kilomètres
il travaille aussi sur de nouvelles
combinaisons qui résisteront à la
terrible poussière lunaire très abrasive
de quoi occuper les ingénieurs pour des
années et permettre de reculer les
limites du voyage spatial
même si les technologies lunaire seront
pas les mêmes que sur mars parquet
l'environnement n'est pas le même
au moins on apprendra ce que c'est que
s'installer avec un habitat avec db ce
ravitailleur qui atterrissent certain
qu'ils vont explorer et tout ça en
coopération internationale c'est un
endroit assez proches que l'on voit
toujours elle fait toujours rêver parce
qu'elle est là dans ciel et qui en une
dizaine d'années permet de faire quelque
chose de concret pour réduire les
risques le vaisseau lunaire et
l'équipage seront lancés sur deux fusées
différentes
une fois réunis en orbite ils entameront
le voyage vers la lune
le module 3 fois plus grand que celui
d'apollo débarquera quatre hommes et du
matériel
les astronautes vont rester sur la lune
pendant au moins une semaine contre
trois jours au maximum pour les missions
apollo
une fois toutes ces techniques
maîtrisées il faudra ensuite choisir un
site sans doute au pôle sud de la lune
pour accueillir et assembler une base
permanente
mais pour cela il faudra un habitat de
l'énergie de l'oxygène de l'eau de la
nourriture un véritable casse-tête
technologique à résoudre avant
d'envisager un éventuel voyage vers mars
voilà pour mieux comprendre nicolas
chateauneuf nous a rejoint bonsoir
nicolas au final pourquoi vouloir
retourner sur la lune que va-t-on y
chercher et bien ta ville il ya
plusieurs raisons d'abord une raison
politique
après la navette spatiales ou la station
spatiale internationale et bien il faut
un nouvel objectif à la nasa ce sera la
lune et puis attention il ya nouveau de
nouveaux concurrents la hausse comme les
chinois installé une nouvelle base ça
veut dire également faire de la
recherche on parle d'exploiter des
ressources minières on parle également
d'installer soit face cachée de la lune
un énorme télescopes géants qui pourrait
ressembler à ça
construire une nouvelle base lunaire
cela veut dire également mettre au point
de nouveaux modules d'habitation de
nouvelles sources d'énergie de nouveaux
véhicules d'exploration des nouvelles
capsules d'évacuation autant de
techniques qui devraient permettre de
faire des voyages spatiaux plus longs et
donc plus loin mais alors justement si
l'objectif est d'aller sur mars pour
quoi faire de la lune une étape
intermédiaire bien il faut une
répétition générale david et la lune est
parfaite pour cela avant d'aller sur
mars car la lune est à 380 mille
kilomètres seulement de la terre il faut
trois jours de voyage et les
communications se font en moins d'une
seconde sur mars tout change
la terre et à des dizaines de millions
de kilomètres lorsque vous posez une
question par exemple il faut entre six
et 44 minutes pour qu'elle arrive à
destination
donc les élans spatiale en sont sûrs il
faut d'abord s'entraîner avant de
pouvoir contempler les incroyables
paysages martiens
attention ce sont de véritables photos
mais attention mars ce ne sera pas avant
merci nicolas chateauneuf pour ses
explications en bref encore à l'étranger
denis sassou n'guesso a été
officiellement réélu président du congo
78% des voix au premier tour résultat
contesté par l'opposition
et puis les obsèques en russie de la
militante des droits de l'homme natalia
estemirova assassinée hier on l'évoquait
le président russe medvedev promet une
enquête les ong et les proches de la
victime montre du doigt
ramzam kadyrov l'homme fort de la
tchétchénie
il est 20h20 resté avec nous à suivre la
famille de l'excellence quatre filles 4
mention très bien au bac jamais sous les
18 de moyenne nous irons à leur
rencontre dans le nord
le pourboire est il en voie de
disparition les français donnent de
moins
au moins certains évoquent la crise et
puis bruce springsteen en france en
bretagne pour un concert unique au
festival des vieilles charrues de
carhaix c'est l'autre événement rock de
la semaine d'abord donc cette famille
invraisemblable est talentueuse elle
s'appelle pauline sophie charlotte et
juliette elles sont soeurs et elles ont
un point commun elles ont toutes
décroché le bac avec mention très bien
et 18 minimum de moyenne à fleurbaix
près de bergues marianne masse patrick
vers stored dans la famille braqué il y
à charlotte mention très bien en 2006 et
cette année sophie et pauline jumelles
dans la vie et dans leur mention je
m'attendais pas à voir cette mention
mais ce que j'ai eu tout au long de
l'année 14 me à peu près donc là je suis
bien monter donc je pense vraiment que
sofia les pins à l'être largement devant
moi même s'ils restent devant moi là je
me suis rapproché de ce lot a fallu une
veste bien surpris d'après moi c'est pas
et j'avais états unis vous que je
m'attendais pas à ça peut être la monf
lyon c'est une double surprise
pourtant chez les bras qui on aurait
presque eu l'habitude de l'excellence
sur la photo de famille les manques
juliette l'aîné ingénieur au texas
mention très bien en 2003 les benjamines
honte assurer la relève avec brio les
jardins que les deux mains sont très
bien ça a fait très très plaisir ensuite
coach nassi les moyennes c'était
vraiment que du bonheur et moi je suis
très contente pour elle
et s'il y a une recette à ce quadruple
succès c'est beaucoup d'attention
beaucoup d'amour comme comme tous les
parents
et puis bon une vigilance quand même
mais on n'est pas les seuls dans cette
réussite puisqu'il ya surtout le travail
de nos filles et puis travail de tous
leurs instituteurs et professeurs depuis
le début de leur scolarité
ma première est ingénieur ma seconde est
un centre alma troisième rentrer en
prépa ma quatrième de faire médecine
il était une fois 4 drôle de fille qui
avait décidé de s'engager dans les
études et d'y réussir et bravo elle en
tout cas faut-il incriminer la crise
ou bien est ce une pratique en voie de
disparition de l'avis général des
professionnels des taxis aux
restaurateurs les pourboires sont en
chute libre cet été
sarrabère du chant jean marc new look
voici une scène de plus en plus rares un
touriste qui demande au garçon de garder
la monnaie
en france les pourboires ne sont déjà
pas obligatoire mais en ces temps
difficiles au restaurant comme dans les
taxis ils deviennent carrément une
exception les gens ne donnent pas de
pourboire
ils sont restreints même aux taxis parce
qu'il ya des problèmes financiers
si le serveur il est triste il est pas
gentil il sourit pas on laissera quoi
plus d'un euro à l'épée 2 euros c'est
vraiment
le serveur ou la serveuse
l'exceptionnel
des pourboires qui ont baissé en moyenne
jusqu'à 30% selon les restaurateurs du
coup dans la cagnotte commune des
serveurs beaucoup de pièces jaunes
centimes 5 centimes ça dépend baisse
moins qu'avant avant la crise
euros la journée
mettant certains 5 euros mais pour voir
en chute libre
une tendance qui pour les professionnels
de la restauration a commencé avec le
passage à l'euro
si le prix de vertu et respect au niveau
de la conversion je pense prison
c'est la monnaie
maintenant comme un électron et ardent
et ans se disent pourquoi donner encore
en revanche du côté des quartiers
touristiques on met toujours aussi
facilement la main au porte monnaie
alors je vais tout c'est 10 euros
désormais je vais toucher 2 euros au
palmarès de la générosité
l'américain occupe la première place
suivie par le russe et le britannique
quant aux touristes français il est l'un
des plus pingres à l'étranger comme à
domicile est toujours à propos des
vacances une alerte au requin ce matin
sur une plage d'antibes
plusieurs personnes ont aperçu un
aileron le drapeau rouge a très vite été
hissé les baigneurs sont tous sortis de
l'eau en fait l'animal suspect était un
poisson lune
aux etats unis c'est bel et bien un
requin pèlerin qui s'est échoué sur une
plage de long island
la bête mesure 6 mètres mais on le sait
elle ne mange de tout façon queue du
peloton
comment un objet comme un accessoire
devient-il à la mode il ya eu les tongs
les crocs les mules mais cet été c'est
le retour conquérant des sandales à
brides multiples et spartiates
alors nous avons voulu savoir d'où
venaient exactement cette chaussure
antique de la ville de ce parc de
l'adjectif spartiates ou bien des
gladiateurs enquête estelle colin samuel
humez
comment interpréter cette déferlante de
spartiates la crise peut-être qui
sacralise ces quelques grammes de qi
matière un peu plus brillante
d'accord c'est le bon modèle météo à
faire débat qui sera fait dans quand
c'était vraiment très très pur on croit
que ces sandales ultra plate viennent de
la ville de sparte erreur à part les
gladiateurs tout le monde a les pieds
nus la petite histoire dit qu'elle est
née à saint tropez entre les deux
guerres d'un cordonnier arméniens une
commande d'un voyageur qui avaient cru
les voir sur les statues romaines
c'est dans l'imaginaire collectif que
nous voyons cela parce que tout
simplement on interprète mal ce que l'on
voit sur les sculptures antiques ou pas
toujours est il que des normes elle
chausse petits et grands nos shows sont
des personnalités les dernières les plus
connues sont la première dame des
etats-unis et la première dame de france
ça c'est leur original tout funny aussi
le style baba cool années 70 aujourd'hui
les stars ne jurent que par elle beyoncé
oumma thurman ou encore gwyneth paltrow
et tout cela un peu grâce à lui au début
il ya quatre ans chez que cela ne serait
qu'un coup de coeur d'un été
puis en repensant aux grands péplums
tels que trois gladiateurs j'ai compris
que ce n'était pas seulement un simple
effet de mode
le passionnant
ni le roi soleil et ses talons ni foule
que le hargneux ces bouts pointus ne
peuvent se vanter d'une telle trouvaille
la spartiate pure invention et d'après
les spécialistes il paraît que l'on en
reprend pour trois mineurs la musique
c'est décidément un été très rock après
you to à saint-denis après johnny paris
voici bruce springsteen
il donne ce soir le coup d'envoi du
festival des vieilles charrues à carhaix
en bretagne avec là encore la grande
foule
quarante trois mille personnes ce soir
pour écouter celui qu'on appelle le boss
antoine gaveau frédéric bonne sur place
c'est un des plus grand showman de la
planète en 37 ans de carrière bruce
springsteen a écumé les plus grandes
salles et les plus grands stades
et ce soir ils jouent ici à
carhaix-plouguer bretagne 8000 habitants
un concert unique et exceptionnel aux
vieilles charrues ou pour le boss on est
venus de toute la france
oya les gens du sud gens du nord il ya
peu de peu de partout mais tous des fans
mais tous des fans voilà vous pouvez
regarder
je suis ravie j'ai pu le voir ça va être
un moment extraordinaire nous tous et
pour cela il s'agit d'être aux premières
loges
alors afin d'approcher un peu plus
l'idole les spectateurs s'improvise
sprinteurs
quand même le contact avec l'artiste qui
est vraiment important surtout pour ce
meeting on voit pas tous les jours donc
ça vaut le coup de faire deux ans de
travaux autre exception bruce
springsteen ne fait jamais de festival
pour le faire venir il aura fallu trois
mois de négociations et mettre la main à
la poche 1 millions d'euros au titre
la magie aller ailleurs le rêve il est
ailleurs les gens vont vivre à jusque
les autres artistes mais oui c'est vrai
on en a on a consacré un budget beaucoup
plus important sur la venue de cet
artiste mais le jeu en valait la
chandelle et puis il a rempli site en
quelques semaines le festival était
complet le festival dure quatre jours
alors au camping on a planté les tentes
au programme après le boss ce soir lenny
kravitz bénabar ou francis cabrel une
image du tour de france avec la victoire
aujourd'hui du danois sorensen dans la
12e étape entre tonnerre et vittel en
sept participations au tour il remporte
à 34 ans la première étape de sa
carrière le maillot jaune de leader
reste sur les épaules de l'italien
nocentini
avant de refermer ce journal je vous en
rappelle l'un des principaux titres cet
accident grave au stade vélodrome à
marseille cet après midi une scène
érigée pour le concert de madonna s'est
effondré il y à un mort et neuf blessés
dont un pour lequel le pronostic vital
est réservé le concert a bien sûr
étaient annulés c'est la fin de cette
édition merci de l'avoir suivi tout de
suite la météo tania young ressortait
les anoraks et
parapluies 20h35 les carnets de voyage
d'envoyé spécial destination les
maldives avec guilaine chenu et
françoise joly pour l'information demain
13h élise lucet ce week-end laurent
delahousse cet olivier galzi vous
retrouverez à cette même place dès lundi
bonnes vacances si vous avez la chance
d'en prendre très bonne soirée et à
bientôt
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur france
2 point fr